How do you deal with being evaluated
specifically by different people with
different opinions and motives?
Oh,
how do you deal with being evaluated?
Well,
I can tell you right now,
nobody likes being
evaluated, right? Nobody.
Now you might get somebody that
says, oh, I love being coached in.
And there are some people that
are pretty positive about that.
And as a matter of fact, I have clients
where they want to be coached, right?
But most people, especially in a normal
environment, like if you got new hires,
someone to coach you.
Okay.
But most people in a normal environment,
they don't like being evaluated.
They don't like being judged,
always judging.
So the first thing you have to do when
it comes to being evaluated is get that
in your head that you like.
Everybody else has defense mechanisms
and they're going to flare up.
As soon as somebody says
something critical of you,
as soon as somebody goes to evaluate you,
your defense mechanisms are going to
go up. And then once that happens,
once you feel those defense mechanisms
go up, you got to put your ego in check.
Mm hmm.
You got to put your ego in
check and then once you do that,
you gotta listen. Listen,
I know it sounds crazy.
Listen to what they're saying.
Don't even,
don't even think of a response.
Say to yourself, you know what,
I'm not even gonna Respond. I'm only going
to listen to what they're saying. Yeah,
but [inaudible] and to kind of cheat
your already can't even take it. No, no,
I can't take it. Oh, I'm saying,
but I think, um, cause people will,
will quote unquote do that, but they
won't really do it as far as just,
I'm not gonna say anything. I'm just
gonna listen there. That's actually,
that's actually like, that's
actually how they set it up to look.
I'm not even gonna say anything. I'm
just going to listen. Yes, exactly.
What I'm talking about is like you
don't owe or they'll all body language,
you know, the kind of where
they are. Like, you know,
they'll do that kind of stuff.
Don't do that. Don't do
that. So you're right.
You got to listen and not just listen to,
but truly listen,
not listen just with your ears,
but listen with your mind and
your brain and with an open mind,
an open mind,
and then think about what people are
saying and then see it is important to see
it from their perspective. Because if
you just see it from your perspective,
you're not even seeing what
the criticism really is.
You're only seeing the
defense of the criticism.
So actually get in their mind and say,
wow,
what does this look like
from their perspective?
Why would they be taking the effort and
the risk and the challenge of trying to
present this problem to me if it wasn't
important or they just doing it just to
make me mad. No, they're trying
to help you. And you know what?
Just like just like a joke
and they say like every joke,
some little truth to it.
Yeah. Every little criticism.
Even if the person is your archrival,
their criticism is built on something.
Yeah.
So what is that reality that
you can take away from it,
even though you've got to take it with a
grain of salt, especially if the person,
like it says here, if the person has
different opinions and mode as well,
of course they have different opinions.
You want people with different opinions,
maybe they have different motives,
so maybe you think they're trying to usurp
your authority or something like that.
So you, maybe you got to
take it with a grain of salt,
but find the grain of truth in there
too and find what it is from their
perspective,
what the problem is and learn from it.
And one of the most beautiful things
about this is you take the criticism and
you make adjustments. You know, how
do I deal with about being evaluated?
I try and accept the evaluation and
make adjustments to improve myself as a
human.
Hmm.
That's how I deal with being evaluated.
And I'm not saying I deal with it
anybody better than anybody else because
everybody gets defensive,
myself included.
Mm.
You know, we had a little conversation
when we started tonight, right? Sure.
You said, I repeated some stuff
on the last podcast, allegedly,
and you know, and then we talked
through it and then I said,
you know,
and you know,
I noticed that your camera work was a
little bit off and you know, it just the,
my point was just to prove how defensive
we all get can yeah. We all get,
and you know what I did? I said, you
know what? I noticed that too, you know,
but as far as me repeating,
there was a couple little sections
and it was because we pulled,
I pulled from multiple different books
and they had a little bit of overlap and
looking back on it probably shouldn't
have. But at the time I thought,
you know what? This is emphasizing
really important points. Yeah.
But still people don't want to hear
the same thing over and over again.
So I probably shouldn't have done that.
So guess what criticism accepted right on.
I will adapt,
adjust,
and I will make improvements to my game
based on your criticism of my technique,
my skill, and my life. Yup.